how could it possibly be expected to go
without Domino's on a day like this
Alexa asked Domino's to place my easier
ordering Domino's life moves pretty fast
that's Joe Curie star of the 1980s
inspired hit stranger things on Netflix
in a commercial for Domino's Pizza
inspired by the comedy classics Ferris
Bueller's Day Off
while the ad has been getting a lot of
buzz it's the actual pizza company
that's hotter than ever and one big
reason has to do with another bit of
marketing seven years ago it helps save
the day when the flatbread company was
flatlining Michelle Miller traveled to
Michigan to find out Domino's recipe for
success if you work for Domino's there's
one skill you must master how to make a
pizza I would go ahead and put it in the
pan just okay in-store training is
required for all corporate employees at
its Ann Arbor Michigan headquarters no
matter their position so if I asked any
of these employees right here I walked
up to one of them and I said what's the
best way to make pizza they'll be able
to every single one of them could do it
Patrick told you I'd know the answer
it's one rule CEO Patrick Doyle left in
place after taking over the helm of the
global chain in 2010 a time very
different than today talk about business
how is business
business is really good so good the
business world is buzzing in the last
seven years the company is outperformed
Amazon Apple Facebook and Google it
stopped going from nine dollars a share
to over 180 dollars today so we were
double digit up in our same store sales
each of the last two years we're
building stores you know we're excited
to understand that excitement you have
to rewind a decade
you know 2006 2008 we had negative sales
in the US people just felt like there
were better pizzas and you know what I'm
gonna buy from somebody else so it was a
question of taste oh absolutely
just before the US economy went belly-up
in 2008 Domino's had a gut check of its
own people were losing their homes and
their mortgages Russell Weiner is
president of Domino's Us stores and all
every American wanted was for someone to
stand up and tell them the truth to
listen to their problem and to do the
right thing that meant dumping their
decades-long marketing campaigns which
branded Domino's on speed you can count
on our famous 30-minute delivery Oh and
doing the unthinkable Domino's Pizza
crust to me is like hard work shooting a
series of commercials inside their own
Test Kitchen admitting their pizza
wasn't so hot there comes a time when
you know you've got to make a change why
did you think it was gonna work because
it was so different oh it smells bad
worst excuse for pizza I've ever had the
sauce tastes like ketchup totally void
of flavor we knew if we walked out and
showed a commercial talking about how
bad our product is it's going to break
through the question is are you going to
persuade them that it's better we went
on air on a Monday and by Wednesday our
sales were up double-digit and we had
even told them how we fixed it well this
is our hand-tossed Oh fixing it took
nearly two years a Herculean task for
head chef Roxanne Wamba and her team
we've changed the flavor of the cheese
the way it melts out we've changed the
sauce and then we've added the garlic
butter to the crust at the end which you
know most people leave their crusts at
then but now
have flavored crust that when you didn't
eat it you can either heat the whole
thing
yeah but taste wasn't the only thing
that evolved the company which two
brothers launched back in nineteen sixty
had grown to 2,000 stores around the
world by the year 2000 it took another
decade before it fully moved into the
21st century in 2009 we decided that
technology was going to be a big deal
I mean you have more people working in
IT than anywhere else I'm anywhere else
in the company yeah it was pretty clear
to us that customers how they were gonna
gonna be ordering from us in the future
was gonna change let's start a new order
great let's get started that meant
developing new ways for customers to
order I think one of the coolest is
being able to place an order using a
pizza emoji a pizza emoji pizza emoji
dennis Maloney is Domino's chief digital
officer so based on your ordering
history it's right quick except so it
knows who you are and knows what you've
saved as your order it knows your
payment information it has everything it
needs to place it so you send us the
pizza emoji and your order is on the way
in in a teenager's hands
this is dangerous or is completely
awesome
it all fits with a product that is
nearly foolproof
the big advantage we have with pizza it
is still the most popular food we beat
burgers and we beat any tacos we beat
anything else the other really big
advantage though that we have for our
model is it delivers well and there are
a lot of foods that don't deliver well
for CBS this morning Saturday Michelle
Miller Ann Arbor Michigan Domino's is
now a truly global brand of their 13,000
stores in 80 countries only 5,000 are
here in the US there are 1,000 in India
alone you don't think of Indian pizza
but the company told us more than half
of all sales are coming through digital
platforms more than half of those are
mobile I'm looking to order my own
masala dosas no ball before I order yoyo
in the New York area what kind of pizza
snobs that is true